by we're havin else that dragon age
inquisition will be getting an epilogue
and a major patch as its final DLC pack
during pax prime Bioware creative
director Mike Laidlaw drop the news that
the upcoming DLC entitled trespasser
will tell an entirely new story set two
years after the main game the story
explores what it's like to be a world
saving organization when the world no
longer needs saving in press pastor
you'll be able to chat with old friends
as you try to uncover in Brett and
according to bioware you will ultimately
decide the fate of the Inquisition you
work so hard to build they also added
that the DLC might just continue hints
about the future of theta trespasser
launches on sep tember 8 and pricing is
yet to be announced though you will need
to finish the main storyline before you
can play it as for the other awesome
using a patch will be coming to the Xbox
one ps4 and PC editions of the game it's
set to include some new features
including a thousand ugh which will let
you sink collectibles across save files
on the same system fire where have said
the stink is bidirectional and additive
which means that any collectibles will
be added to the online collection even
if the character doing the clicking is
pre endgame it's like a new game plus
without having to start a new game the
sync works with things like schematics
potion recipes melts and sky hold
decorations also included in the patch
is a new wardrobe for sky hold so you
don't have to put on those weird base
pajamas every time you get back to your
house or check in with your love
interest the new hatch contains dozens
of outfits in a variety of not beige
colors let me know down in the comments
if you'll be getting back into dragon
age inquisition to check out the final
dlc for everything dragon age and gaming
at be sure of stay tuned to gamespot